a six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to a caller from
Skype who's been holding on for a while
Skype can be dicey when we take callers
from Skype who's this hey David it's
miles again I'm from Arizona
go ahead miles um so like a week ago a
teenager in Utah wore this prom dress
that looked Chinese and people began
accusing her of cultural appropriation
what's your view on cultural
appropriation listen I don't know I have
no clue about the story I think that
there's cultural appropriation in and of
itself is something that can mean very
very different things it can mean some
degree of sort of like disrespect
towards a culture it can also just be
something entering popular culture that
has an origin that is in one place
versus a different place you know I
remember we did a story about a white
guy who had dreadlocks being attacked on
some California College campus for
cultural appropriation by someone who
was black and then it was pointed out
that actually the black community sort
of appropriated the idea of dreadlocks
from some other community and that you
don't hear about that I think the entire
concept of making attacking cultural
appropriation a pillar of any political
movement is dangerous I think that we
should all be willing to explore ways in
which we might be disrespectful to
someone's culture but but as a as a
point of policy I I would not be someone
who makes fighting cultural
appropriation a pillar of any platform
I'd advocate for yeah understandable
also I'm you familiar with the
Vekselberg connection a Michael Cohen
yeah well yes this is the so Vekselberg
is the company tied to a Russian
oligarch
who is Putin connected that reportedly
made a five hundred thousand dollar
payment to a company a shell company
controlled by Michael Cohen along with
AT&T payments as well as Novartis
payments which we've reported on yeah
that's that's a
that's quite a situation yeah I just
find that quite I just find that quite
interesting and I just was wondering it
just seems like the Michael Cohen
scandal just keeps on getting bigger
it's almost you have to wonder if it's
like I don't believe it's separate from
Russia but it's like it's almost getting
to the level of Trump Russia would you
agree or not yeah yeah I actually said
earlier this week on the basis of the
revelations about the shell company and
the payments that I think it actually is
too big now for Robert Muller like there
needs to be an investigation that just
focuses on the Coen elements because the
Coen element of criminality of potential
criminality has gotten so big that it
almost is going to take attention away
from all the other stuff Robert Muller
is investigating I totally agree with
you models yeah all right thank you so
much really appreciate the call always
great to uh always great to hear from
Miles for sure